la mathématique et l'art de donner le
même nom à des choses différentes
cette isation et de poincaré et
bizarrement il s'agit peut-être de l'une
des définitions les plus pertinentes qui
soit de la mathématique
en tout cas c'est une de mes citations
préférées et je sais qu'il ya certains
de mes compères matheux du web qui
partagent cet avis autant dire que le
concept sur lequel repose cette citation
est l'un des concepts les plus
fondamentaux et les plus profonds des
mathématiques
ce concept est le concept d'iso mort
fils et je vous promets que dénicher des
isomorphisme est l'une des plus grande
joie des mathématiques je vous propose
de le découvrir en retraçant l'un des
plus beaux isomorphisme découverte dans
l'histoire des sciences en 1925 bourdon
et le grand werner heisenberg
proposèrent expliquer les bizarreries de
mécanique quantique et du modèle de bord
par des tableaux de nombres appelé
matrice la théorie de la mécanique
matricielle de l'iceberg et est
abstraite est impossible visualiser mais
ça marchait quelques mois plus tard en
1926 volcan paoli déduisit des matrices
de heisenberg les bons niveaux d'énergie
des électrons de l'atome d'hydrogène se
pendant à peu près au même moment
r une chouette inger s'isola en montagne
pour mieux réfléchir choix d'une guerre
s'appuya sur la dualité 11 clos
puisqu'il suggéré par lui de brogues
quelques mois plus tôt en 1925
schrödinger fut persuadé que les ondes
quantique devaient être les vrais objets
de la mécanique quantique
il partit en quête une équation
fondamentale qui prédit ray la dynamique
de ces ondes quantique
l'équation de schrödinger découvrit est
ce que l'on appelle aujourd'hui
l'équation de schrödinger cette équation
merveilleuse est la version quantique du
principe fondamental de la dynamique et
de façon stupéfiante
cette équation prédit les bons niveaux
d'énergie des électrons de l'atome
d'hydrogène ainsi en 1926 le monde de la
physique disposait alors de deux
théories distinctes
quantic une matrice de heisenberg et les
ondes du chevreuil dinger et toutes deux
effectué les mêmes bonnes prédictions
mais alors laquelle de ces deux théories
[Musique]
deux clans se formèrent l'abstraction
algébrique impossible de visualiser de
heisenberg et paoli contrôler les ondes
et la position réaliste de schrödinger
et einstein paoli à plat les ondes de
choix zinger des superstitions local de
zurich tandis que schrödinger se disait
décourager voire repoussées par les
méthodes d d'alger transcendante de
heisenberg en septembre 1927
la lumière vint de l'étoile montante de
la mécanique quantique
l'anglais paul dirac d'irak prouva que
les formalismes de heisenberg et de
schrödinger était en fait deux façons
distinctes de paris d'une même théorie
sous jacente de la mécanique quantique
mieux encore d'irak réussi à unifier ses
deux théories avec la théorie de la
relativité restreinte d'einstein et
construisit ainsi de nouvelles théories
de la mécanique quantique la théorie
quantique des champs
ce que j'aimerais que vous retenez de
cette histoire c'est que eisenberg et
trading heures avait proposé deux
théories qui semblait complètement
différente elle introduisait chacune
leur propre objet quantique cependant
dira que mon trac les différences entre
ces deux théories n'était qu'apparente
il existait même une façon de traduire
tout objet fondamentale d'une théorie en
un objet fondamental de l'autre
théorique et vice et versa si on omet
des détails qui finalement ne sont en
fait pas important on se rend compte que
ces deux théories sont équivalentes
on dit que les deux théories sont
isomorphe et les manières de traduire
les objets d'une théorie en lin et vice
et versa sont appelés dès isomorphisme
ça me rappelle quand j'étais en tête et
qu'on jouait aux cartes le midi certains
puristes psychorigide insisté sur
l'ordre dans lequel on devait piocher
les cartes de la pioche et je répondais
mais ça change rien mais après avoir
tiré leur carte
il me rétorque m ah si je peux te
promettre que ça change quelque chose
l'ordre dans lequel on tire les cartes
de la pioche change en effet quelque
chose a posteriori cependant scellé
carte son
mélangez alors avant d'être révélé
toutes les cartes de la pioche sont
indistinct gablé du coup l'ordre dans
lequel on va tirer ces cartes a priori
ne devrait pas affecter la manière dont
on pense le jeu les stratégies que l'on
a mises en place pour gagner ni même les
espérances de gains des différents
joueurs
à ce jeu et c'est ce que je me tue à
expliquer arrêtez d'être psychorigide
bon sens c'est isomorphe l'histoire des
sciences et des mathématiques est
parsemé de découverte de tels
isomorphisme d'instants où l'on découvre
tout à coup que des théories a priori
concurrentes sont en fait deux faces
d'une même pièce
dans la série sur la relativité on en a
vu plusieurs exemples on a ainsi vu le
principe de relativité de galilée selon
lequel le mouvement et comme rien en
vertu du principe de relativité de
qualité et ça deviendra encore plus
clair suit alors la qualité générale
d'einstein l'héliocentrisme et le
géocentrisme sont en fait deux théories
izumo reformuler de la bonne manière
chacune de ces deux théories et dans
fuck aussi valable l'une que l'autre
de même le principe d'équivalence
d'einstein nous dit qu'il existe en
isolement fils mme han min clouteau nien
entre les référentiels soumis à un champ
de pesanteur et ce en accélération et ça
ça veut dire qu'il n'y a aucune
expérience que vous pouvez faire à la
surface de la terre pour vous convaincre
qu'il existe une vraie force de gravité
qui vous tirent vers le bas et non que
le sol est en fait en train taxer les
faits vers le haut einstein poussa même
l'argument encore plus loin en supposant
que la gravité n'existe en fait pas et
que tous les référentiels que l'on croît
avec un chant de pesanteur sont en fait
des référentiels accélérée par ailleurs
on a vu que l'analogie de la toile
combiné avec le fait que tout objet sur
cette toile descend la toile avec une
accélération proportionnelle à la
direction et à l'intensité de plus
grande pente est isomorphe à la théorie
newtonienne de la gravité histoire d'en
remettre une couche
mon problème avec l'utilisation de cette
analogie ce n'est pas parce que ça
représente mal compris de l'espace temps
si c'est vrai mon gros problème
c'est qu'il s'agit d'une analogie
purement newtonienne est absolument pas
einstein yens un autre exemple disons
morphisme dont on a parlé dans un vieil
épisode est celui que john nash a prouvé
entre les géométries extrinsèque qui est
la géométrie des hypers surface dans des
espaces de très grandes dimensions et
les géométries intrinsèque qu'invente à
bernhard riemann écoeuré utilisa
einstein pour développer sa relativité
générale
enfin dans notre série sur l'infini on a
vu différentes manières de définir les
nombres entiers naturels
on peut ainsi les définir comme étant
les objets de l'arithmétique de p and o
comme étant les éléments d'un ensemble
de la théorie zdf c'est celle sur
laquelle s'est reposé nicolas bourbaki
ou alors me demanderiez vous qu'est ce
qu'un nombre est ce que c'est un objet
de l'arithmétique de p and o où est ce
que c'est un ensemble deux élèves c'est
la réponse suggéré par poincaré est la
suivante
pourvu que les objets des axiomes de p
and o les éléments de l'ensemble n2 lfc
et les nombreux qu elle on pense
intuitivement sont essentiellement les
mêmes ou pour être plus précis pourvu
que ces structures sont isomorphe ou
s'en fout on s'en fout de leur origine à
l'instar des théories de rheinberg et
schwinger les définitions précises des
objets qu'on introduit importe en fait
peu ce qui importe c'est que les
différentes définitions qu'une tonne
soit mise aux normes ainsi si l'on en
croit poincaré tous les référentiels en
translation rectiligne uniforme mérite
un mot qui les désigne tous même s'ils
sont en fait différents
on les appelle des référentiels qu'à
lille est en de même tous les
référentiels sans accélération mérite
une même appellation on les appelle des
géodésique de l'espace temps qui plus
est l'analogie de la toile et les
équations de nikon mérite un seul et
même nom où les appelle la théorie de la
gravité de newton
par ailleurs la géométrie extrinsèque
des supers surface et la géométrie
intrinsèque de riemann mérite même car
nos vies où les appelle la géométrie
différentielle
enfin tous les objets qui satisfont les
axiomes de l'arithmétique de paix à nos
mérites
non mais appelle des anti naturel même
s'ils ne sont pas forcément
techniquement les objets de l'art et
critique de pf bref contrairement à ce
que l'on vous dit parfois à l'école les
définition rigoureuse des objets
mathématiques importe finalement peu
limite
osef ce qui importe vraiment
mathématiques ce sont les relations
entre les objets et les structures que
ces relations forme
c'est ainsi que l'on peut obtenir par
des voies très différentes deux
structures dont les objets sont liés de
la même manière si tel est le cas
ou plus précisément si on arrive à
exhiber une façon de traduire les objets
de la première structure des objets de
seconde structure en préservant les
notions de relations entre les
différents objets des deux structures
alors on aura alors construit un nid
zoomorphisme et conformément à la
citation de poincaré
on pourra donner le même nom à ces
structures différentes et ça c'est
peut-être le principe le plus important
de toutes les mathématiques dernière
fois on a parlé de cinq mathématiques
alternatif et pierrot de magnus me
demande quels sont les défauts de la
théorie de tarse qui nous avons des
nombres réels qui sont capables de
définir et n'ont rien de manière décide
à bhl bien le problème avec cette
définition des nombreux réel c'est
qu'elle nous permet de parler que des
nombres réels de la multiplication et de
l'addition et en particulier on ne peut
pas construire des fonctions plus
sophistiqués comme l'exponentielle le
sinus le cosinus où tout joueur de
fonction on ne peut pas faire d'analysé
plus généralement on peut pas parler du
drame des valeurs intermédiaires ou de
la dérive et six objets très très très
important pour faire de la physique
notamment
bref avec la théorie décors réels clos
de tarse qui on peut pas faire grand
chose
john quart d'heure nous demande si l'on
peut parler d' angles dans la théorie de
tard ce qui est bien en fait ce que
permet de faire la géométrie de tarse
qui c'est
pas mal ce que permet de faire au
quotidien
donc tout ce que vous pouvez faire dans
un client a parlé d angle de 45° de 90°
faire la dissection des photons genre
sont des choses que l'on peut faire dans
la théorie de tarse qui ce que le ne
peut pas faire c'est construire
n'importe quel angle
par exemple il est est impossible de
faire une tri section ou de définir un
angle d'un septième de tours de taux
divisé par cette radio et tout ça c'est
très bien sûr à l'histoire de la
géométrie d'euclide en fait ces
problèmes-là latry section d'un angle ou
la construction d'un angle d'un septième
de tours ce sont des problèmes qui
avaient été posées par les grecs et
qu'ils n'ont pas été résolus pendant des
millénaires littéralement et ce n'est
que avec l'avènement de la théorie des
nombres notamment des théories de gosses
ou encore de gallois que l'on aura fini
par comprendre vraiment quelles sont les
nombres que l'on peut construire à la
règle ou pas et du coup quelles sont les
angles que l'on peut bien définir dans
la géométrie de tarski bref la géométrie
de terre ce qui permet de parler des
angles mais elle ne permet pas de
construire n'importe quel tout comme
elle ne permet pas de construire
n'importe quel rapport de longueur
notamment peut pas faire un segment qui
est dix fois plus long qu'un autre
segment
et ça ça me fait penser à un mini défilé
je vous propose le mini défilé suivant
écrire dans le langage de la géométrie
de karski le fait que deux angles soient
égaux mater magique nous demande aussi
ce que j'ai écrit dans cette image-là ne
correspond pas en fait plutôt ici à la
consistance de la théorie et non pas la
preuve de la consistance de la théorie
en fait mater magic a parfaitement
raison ce qu'il y assez qu'il faut
distinguer le mot consistance ici qui
est à l'est la consistance intrinsèque
de la théorie une espèce de consistance
transcendante ou une consistance au fait
que l'on peut déterminer en regardant la
théorie depuis l'extérieur de la théorie
et le concept de consistance à
l'intérieur de la théorie exprimé par
une formule logique parfois je voulais
pas rentrer dans ce petit détail
technique
extrêmement subtile mais en effet la
consistance intrinsèque de la théorie la
consistance du de la théorie vu de
l'extérieur un pic son inconsistance à
l'intérieur de la théorie et comme
l'instant six ans à l'intérieur de la
théorie n'est pas l'opposé de la
consistance vu de l'extérieur de la
théorie cette phrase là n'est pas auto
contradictoires et c'est pour éviter ce
détail technique ultra subtil que une
fois je faisais pas présenter les choses
quelques jours à dieu enfin un pool frau
et de max max me propose d'autres
interprétations du fait qu'une théorie
aux médias inconsistante peuvent être
consistante ce qu'ils nous disent très
juste titre c'est que l'existence de cet
objet n peut correspondre à un objet n
qui n'est pas un nombre entier standard
qui sont et entier qui à partir des
branches parallèle dont on avait parlé
de l'existence
l'épisode 14 sur le terme de gucci taryn
est en effet l'arithmétique de canaux ne
permet pas justement de construire des
nombres entiers naturels qui sont
toujours isolées of à aux antilles
naturel que l'on pense intuitivement
c'est là qu'il faut faire une différence
entre l'arithmétique de p and o et les
axiomes de pernod parce que les axiomes
de p and o eux qui sont formés logique
du second ordre ces axiomes deux
périodes du saumon tordre sont capables
eux de définir une théorie unique des
nombres entiers naturels dans le sens où
tout modèle des axiomes de piano et
isomorphe à aux antilles naturel que
l'on pense intuitivement bref vérité
meetic de piano n'est pas capable elle
de dire que l'on a que des anti naturel
qui sont les anti naturel intuitif et du
coup ci n dans cette formule là ne
correspond pas à un des vrais
antinaturel des sorties nature et le
standard alors on ne peut pas le décoder
avec les formules de google et du coup
le décodage de ce nombre entier non
standard ne correspond pas à une vraie
preuve
en effet ça c'est certainement la
meilleure façon d'expliquer que des
théories oméga inconsistante peuvent
être consistante
ceci étant dit on peut aussi y voir là
une limite évidente des l'arithmétique
de pernod le fait que cette arithmétique
de paix à nos elle nous permet pas de
parler uniquement des objets que l'on
peut construire avec l'arithmétique de
pernod puisque dans cette arithmétique
de panneaux il peut y avoir des objets
que l'on ne peut pas construire et ça
pour quelqu'un qui suit pas la logique
classique pour ce qu'on avait
l'intuition nist c'est quelque chose qui
est complètement débile
on sait qu'on est du coup une intuition
liste va vouloir faire table rase de la
logique classique dont on a parlé jusque
là et c'est en en parlera la prochaine
fois et j'espère que j'avais aimé cette
vidéo la prochaine fois on parlera donc
de la différence entre la logique
classique logique intuition liste et en
particulier on fera le lien entre cette
question fondamentale des mathématiques
est une question philosophique
fascinante qui est la question est ce
que les maths son invention aux
centaines découverte par ailleurs je
sais que les dernières vidéos de sant
paroles sont d'autant plus
incompréhensibles
de plus en plus abstraite est difficile
à suivre mais heureusement je crains que
ce soit un petit peu inévitable je fais
de mon mieux pour rendre évident est
aussi simple que possible mais là on
rentre dans des thèmes de mathématiques
assez assez abstrait qui me fascine
complètement donc j'ai vraiment vraiment
envie d'en parler mais je sais aussi que
du coup je perds pas mal d'entre vous a
causé la difficulté du sujet si c'est le
cas pour vous rassurez vous on a bientôt
fini avec cette série sur infinie et
après cette cession a fini on va
redescendre un peu plus sur terre avec
des sujets de maths plus abordable
comment j'ai envie d'aborder des trucs
sont plus des maths appliquées parce que
c'est un peu de ce que je préfère y aura
l'occasion de faire un vote et tout ça
ça va venir si vous avez aimé ces
épisodes seront celles de l'ikea le
commenter à le partager pensez à vous
abonner pour ne pas manquer les futurs
épisodes merci aussi peur pour leurs
dons et j'espère que je verrai la
prochaine fois on se cache le principe
et parapluies se retrouve vraiment dans
des tas de domaines des mathématiques on
le retrouve un peu partout si jamais
vous faites des études de maths vous
retrouverez par exemple dans une formule
de changement de base avec des matrices
vous le retrouverez par exemple aussi en
théorie des groupes c'est ce qu'on
appelle des autos morphisme intérieur
vraiment ce principe se trouve à
différents endroits et est extrêmement
utile pour beaucoup d'applications en
maths